that's what was so interesting to me was  you could just things that I never  noticed in society I just started to  notice and people say you get  brainwashed blah blah blah and so then I  what I was thinking is I could start to  create cultural moments where I've heard  what the men are saying I've heard what  the women are saying let's bring two  ends of the opposite Spectrum together  and make a video make content and it's  so important because we have so much  media out there that's so tailored to  women this is the one that's for men and  more and it doesn't even need to be for  men men just find it more palatable it's  honest it's more real